Hi I'm Paul Lewis and
I'm a Developer Advocate at Google.
>> And I'm Cameron Pittman.
I make front end web development
courses here at Udacity.
We're here to help you develop
apps that run at a silky smooth
60 frames per second.
And you may think it's just JavaScript
that you need to worry about but
there's actually a lot
more to it than that.
This course is about changing the way
that you approach performance issues.
We're going to help you
look at the bigger picture.
>> Okay let's play a game.
This was made by my
colleague Jake Archibald and
it's designed to show off problems with
frame rates and performance on the web.
See these ships at the top?
They move smoothly.
The ones at the bottom judder.
The game is super simple,
shoot the juddering ships as quickly
as you can by clicking on them.
You're going to have to spot
them amongst the smooth ones.
>> Okay,
I'm going to shoot the juddering ships.
That's a hard, weird British word.
>> It's an amazing British word.
>> I think you made it up.
>> It's just English,
which means I can't be wrong.
>> That's not true.
>> That's very true.
You are not doing well.
>> That's not great.
Well anyway, I hit the wrong one, but
I hope you could do a lot better.